okay thank you all for joining us
um it's my delight today to introduce
john t
seidel who is the sir patrick gillum
professor of international
and comparative politics at the london
school of economics and political
science
professor seidel holds a ba and an m.a
from yale
and received his phd from cornell
i pulled up his dissertation from
cornell just to look at the
acknowledgements page
and i won't go into all the nitty gritty
details but
i was interested to know that he's been
involved in the study of philippines in
southeast asia since at least 1985
when he had an internship in manila but
as he says in the acknowledgements page
of the dissertation
he was only able to detach himself from
from what he calls his quote
adolescent adventures in the realm of
u.s foreign policy
end quote and then become a serious
southeast asianist
after attending yale where he
then went on to become known for his
erudite critiques of the legacy
of u.s policy in the philippines so i'd
like to think that it's yale's
council on southeast asian studies that
had a formative role in his career
as an undergraduate at yale he studied
with al conklin
and jim scott and then he went on to
study with ben anderson at cornell
i like to mention these yale to cornell
stories
uh because there really are several um
eric taglicosa comes to mind
tom popinski also comes to mind people
going from yale and then
taking up positions at cornell um
because they also remind me of my own
passage from
the other direction from cornell to yale
and they really bring up and solidify
all the connections and
mutual inspiration we have and that we
get from each other across this yale
cornell
network but i also hope that today's
talk can be part of an ongoing
connection
between yale southeast asian studies in
the lsc where john has been teaching
since 2004
and also so as where he taught before
that
in other universities working on
southeast asia in the uk i really hope
that we can
forge some more transnational
connections for the study of southeast
asian studies
john seidel as you know is the author of
numerous books and articles
i'm just going to mention some of them
capital coercion and crime which emerged
from that dissertation
bossism in the philippines stanford
university press 1999
co-authored with eva lotta-hedman is a
philippine politics and society in the
20th century colonial legacies
post-colonial trajectories 2000
riots pogroms jihad religious violence
in indonesia
cornell press 2006 the islamist threat
in southeast asia a reassessment for the
east west center in 2007
along with jaime faustino thinking and
working
politically in development coalitions
for change in the philippines
published for the asia foundation and
2020
and of course the book will be learning
about today
uh republicism republicanism
communism islam cosmopolitan origins of
revolution in southeast asia
which is just out now from cornell
university press
uh literally just off the press here in
2021
i'll stop my comments there just so we
can really spend all our time listening
to john
but please do join me in welcoming john
seidel for today's discussion
of his new book john um
many thanks eric for that very generous
uh
introduction i'm not sure i deserve it
at all but certainly yale deserves my
thanks
for and the council for southeast asian
studies and these brown bag seminars for
first drawing me into
that sense of community that kind of uh
cosmopolitan
archipelagic uh network as you put it
some call it a mafia
across southeast asian studies centers
and
universities across the world so it's
been a pleasure and a privilege
and i hope that i i will honor
some of the people here actually i've
seen are attending in terms of their
work
uh by talking about my book which which
i hope is uh in some ways uh
can be understood as a tribute to a
broader uh
set of trends in the historiography of
southeast asia
so what i'd like to do today is
give you uh a flavor of the book and
also give you a sense of its structure
and uh and the core argument and in
doing so
i will now you know throw up some
powerpoint slides in large measure
um photos uh because sadly the book is
not filled with photos
um as it it perhaps would be better
uh embellished with photos but at least
this gives some of the the flavor and
evokes some of the
the kind of lived realities um that i'm
trying to evoke in the book
so there we see the the title so in
terms of the flavor for the book
um uh i should acknowledge that
the book has a kind of a seemingly
rambling
uh narrative style in the beginning of
the chapters
on the successive revolutions that i
treat
and and it begins in seemingly strange
places
so for example the uh the first
two chapters following the introduction
two chapters in the philippine
revolution
begin in the obscure small town of lito
mierche
which is perhaps 45 minutes northwest of
prague in what today is the
the the czech republic in bohemia and
the area that
hitler called the sudetenland and the
czechs called the pochranichi the
borderlands
uh with uh with germany uh and
german-speaking areas
uh and uh i i began here
in in no small measure because uh this
town was
and bohemia more generally was kind of a
seriously contested site
during the reformation and even before
that in terms of christianity
and played host for many uh years for
centuries to a jesuit seminary
and it's in this context of a broader
orbit
of what i call catholic cosmopolitanism
that we see connections between the
philippines and this town
in the person of ferdinand blumentrit a
man who
corresponded closely and expressed great
sympathies and support for
uh jose rizal the the great philippine
novelist and nationalist icon
in the late 19th century as he faced a
series of of
trials and tribulations in his last
years including his eventual execution
by the spaniards but here although lito
mierce has its own history in kind of
czech nationalist uh you know
uh history uh i think what's interesting
is that
blumentritt himself was was no supporter
of czech nationalism
he was a supporter of a german liberal
uh tradition and uh envisaged and
supported a german liberal future
for bohemia as part of a a broader
german-speaking
kind of context as we know from the
austro-hungarian empire
and and yet his background and his
connections to rizal
can be understood within this broader
orbit of
catholic cosmopolitanism that's so
deeply rooted in that setting
that the the czech saint the bohemian
saint
john nepamuki uh 14th century saint
um is a a sort of common feature
of many uh sort of municipal plazas and
churches
and of public life in the philippines as
in many other parts of the world known
as
uh san juan nepo meseno and in fact one
of the
most prominent political families in the
province of uh pampanga
that i i recall encountering 1987 when
uh the uncle of this fellow was
assassinated the nepa mesano family
they're
they're a wealthy powerful family with a
series of of supermarkets nepo marts
around the province so there are traces
of bohemian
catholicism uh in the philippines that
go far beyond
uh the jesuit seminary the gymnasium
where blumenthritt taught and the
correspondence between him
and rizal it's no coincidence as it were
in a similar but different vein i begin
the five chapters
on the indonesian revolution in the
early 20th century oil boom
context of the city of baku today the
capital
of the azerbaijan republic
which in the early 20th century was
notable for
a number of distinctive features on the
one hand given the oil boom
it was one of the most industrialized
towns or cities
in the muslim world and in this way
resemble indonesia
with its uh early forms of
industrialized
wage labor and industrial uh production
especially in those areas
connected to port harbors through
railroads uh
linked up to the the great sugar
plantations uh
of java and parts of sumatra at the time
and baku
um was like indonesia by the turn of the
20th century
a hub for new forms of
islamic modernism and expression and
activism for example the political party
musevet
that emerged in the wake of the sort of
very tumultuous period of world war one
but it was also uh a hub for uh
revolutionary socialism
so joseph stalin as we know him today
spent a great deal of his time in the
early 1900s
as a kind of uh gangster kidnapper
revolutionary
uh and lothario uh in in in
uh baku uh and uh we know that
um in the aftermath of world war one
after a brief experiment with an
independent azerbaijan
republic that we find baku
as a hub for bolshevik propaganda
within and beyond the russian empire
with the 1920 congress of the peoples of
the east
and what we can see here that's quite
interesting is an effort to combine
the energies and aspirations that we
associate with
uh revolutionary socialism and communism
on the one hand
uh and what was then termed pan-islam on
the other
with at this congress the uh ukrainian
jew
gregory zin zinoviev uh calling for a
jihad
against uh that's the word he used
against british and french
imperialism uh something that um was
taken up
in the context of uh growing awareness
uh of uh struggles among muslim peoples
in uh in far-flung places uh far from
baku
that might be connected up through
communism and islam
and although there were no
representatives from indonesia
at the time in 1920 there were
representatives of the communist party
of holland who would go on to play an
important role in indonesian
history and in the making of communism
there and at the congress
there uh there was a poem that was read
out slightly adulterated
by the akhmaest poet sergey gorodetsky
about the coffee plantations and the
exploitation
of plantation workers in java so there
was already in the air some interest in
indonesia
and indeed two years later when they
held a similar
common turn congress in moscow they
invited
tom malacca who had risen
to take over the communist party of
indonesia founded in 1920
and he spoke briefly about the
possibilities of linking up
communism and pan-islam as it was then
called
before he was kind of rudely interrupted
and if you read the stenographic notes
you'll see he was kind of
forcibly basically shut up and forced
off the stage
as this was not convenient and as just
as he became subsequently marginalized
uh likewise the the local uh head of the
so-called muslim commission within the
uh people's commissariat
for uh nationalities headed by stalin
mir said sultan galiyev with his
his aspirations for muslim communism
disappeared
not only marginalized but eventually
imprisoned in the gulags and executed
years later so we can see in baku
the early possibility but then the
the the failed um kind of consummation
uh of a possible alliance between forces
acting in the name of
revolutionary socialism or communism on
the one hand and islam on the other
something that's
crucial for understanding the indonesian
revolution
and finally if we take the vietnamese
revolution which i treat in
the final three chapters of the book
before the conclusion
i begin much more predictably in the
southern chinese
city of guangzhou which is often
referred to in the 19th centuries and
earlier
as canton in western sources and this is
probably
more understandable or obvious as as a
move
uh given uh the close connections
that i'll talk about between what
becomes vietnam
uh and guangzhou and southern china more
generally but it's also understandable
in the sense that guangzhou was
as some have described the cradle of the
revolution in china
it's after all uh the the city uh from
which or at least around which
we see the great luminaries of the late
19th century chinese intellectual
revolutions kang yuwei
and lyang chi chao if we think of sunyat
sen
he uh he comes from a a family and
emigrates
a family that emigrates from guangdong
province and from the pearl river
delta and he ends up back in guangzhou
heading up a nationalist government
after the the first chinese
revolution that overthrew the qing
dynasty such that when
uh ho chi minh as we now know him
arrived in guangzhou
in 1924 he found it as the
the city as the hub and the capital of
the nationalist government
trying to reclaim china but also as a
hub
for various forms of experiments with
radical politics
it's in guangzhou where you see
the hong kong canton semen strike
being carried out with sympathy and
support and solidarity
it's in guangzhou that we see that the
short-lived commune
after the uh the breakdown of the
guamadang chinese communist party
alliance in 1927
it's in guang uh guangzhou that we see
the wampua or huangpu uh military
academy
with soviet advisors training
nationalists and communists and some
vietnamese
uh military uh cadets uh
and for military training um in in ways
that prove crucial for the chinese and
vietnamese
revolutions and it's also interestingly
enough
uh around guangzhou that we see the
first chinese communist party
experiments with peasant
organizing under the leadership of
mending pongpai
with the peasant movement training
institute where mao xitong
first began to articulate and undertake
peasant organizing intellectual
activities
uh something that vietnamese activists
were drawn into as well
so it's pretty obvious why i would start
in guangzhou and so i'm perhaps sounding
a little bit more
sensible for southeast asianists but
here just to
you know confuse things a bit i also
include in the introduction to these
vietnamese chapters
the chapters on the vietnamese
revolution um a discussion of the city
uh once known as tana narive now as
antanarivo
the capital of madagascar because it's
worth noting
that in the early aftermath of world war
one
um the or during world war one itself
the hundred thousand vietnamese soldiers
and workers
who were drawn to france and europe to
support the french war effort
find themselves with hundreds of
thousands of more
african soldiers and workers and some
chinese
soldiers and workers as well or at least
workers and
they mix and mingle with them and get
drawn into forms of political activism
that are significant and are enabling
and encouraging of forms of activism
that take on a life of their own
in other parts of the world as we'll see
and there's a kind of reprise
of this linkage in 1947 really the the
darkest most difficult year
for the viet minh as they're fighting uh
the french
and it's happily enough for them the
year where there's an
insurrection in madagascar that
distracts
the french troops and draws french
troops away to put down very brutally
and violently
uh an insurrection in this african uh
island and and french colony at the time
so in other words i'm trying to evoke
the the kind of
uh entanglement of vietnam's revolution
with a broader arc of developments and
trends that extend not only to
neighboring china
no big news there perhaps but also
extrapolating a bit
in terms of an african connection as
well
okay so so far so confusing and so far
from southeast asia
but just to reassure you there's a kind
of method to the madness
and much of the action and much of the
point really has to do with southeast
asia i can promise you that
uh and and here i think the argument
that i'm making is framed uh for
this audience and for the book as a
whole uh
not for scholars of revolution not for
political scientists
but for people interested in southeast
asian studies and it's framed in the
context of what seemed to me to be two
crucial distinctive features of
southeast asian studies
especially in that kind of cornell yale
nexus or axis or corridor
that eric was was mentioning and it
seems to me that the two distinctive
features of southeast asian studies
that i'm writing in the context of and
in some measure
uh against um are as follows
first of all a tendency to
uh to to uh
to to kind of um what's the word to a
kind of preoccupation
uh with the uh the notion of the
autonomy and
in john smales terms and authenticity of
southeast asia and southeast asians
rather than uh an understanding of
southeast asia as a kind of
you know poor man's or poor woman's kind
of version
of a bigger better civilization next
door
whether in india or in china
in other words a notion that in order to
to study southeast asia you know that
the we don't want to be
uh second-rate third-rate orientalists
uh we want to
you know claim that there's something
distinctive about southeast asia and you
can't understand it
um unless you if you just think that uh
it's a cheap imitation
of something from beyond and this
preoccupation
is evident if we think of o.w walter's
famous account of khmer hinduism
where he tells us that khmer hinduism is
as khmer as it is hindu
clifford clifford gertz's account of
religion on java that islam is as
javanese as it is anything else on java
and vince rafael's account of what's
gained
and lost in in the translation uh
of spanish catholicism and latin roman
catholicism
uh into tagalog um in the early
uh period of spanish colonial rule in
the philippines in the 16th and 17th
centuries
so this is one kind of preoccupation
that i think
is very striking about southeast asian
studies and the second
is a preoccupation with nationalism and
here i'm talking about a preoccupation
that's there very much in the 60s and
70s
and 80s in the cold war era in which
scholars of southeast asia opposed to
u.s involvement in indochina opposed to
various forms of u.s intervention in the
region are understandably concerned
to argue and uh and
and show how uh for various forms of
anti-imperialism
in southeast asia uh are reflective of
authentic forms of nationalism
rather than just a bunch of fellow
travelers
uh or communists in disguise and so
there's a great deal of
of energy and effort devoted to
uh the analysis of nationalism in
southeast asia
and it's in this context this cold war
context it seems to me
that we see the uh production and
publication
by benedict anderson of the single most
interesting important
uh and uh insightful book that we have
about nationalism in general imagine
communities
and it seems to me that since the
publication of this book
in 1983 it's worth noting with opening
pages that
that really emphasize the cold war
context in which it's written
the so-called second cold war under
ronald reagan
uh before mikhail gorbachev assumes
office
in moscow um that we see the creation of
a kind of template
for understanding southeast asian
history a template
that came to be dominant by the end of
the 20th century in the study of
southeast asia
and this template sort of works as
follows
fairly clearly and coherently and here
concisely
namely that we see from the relative
incoherence and fuzziness
of loosely structured dynastic realms up
into the
19th century we see with the rise of
modern mostly colonial states
in the late 19th and early 20th century
the creation of administrative
structures and then parallel
school systems and languages of state
that enable the emergence and expansion
of forms of shared experience expression
uh understanding self-understanding and
consciousness that are
proto-nationalists and enable and impel
nationalist forms of mobilization and
then give rise to
new nation states by the mid late
20th century and so this creates for us
and has has established quite
conveniently
for uh people teaching southeast asian
history a kind of neat template
for understanding uh a kind of teleology
for understanding modern southeast asian
history
but this template it seems to me raises
two questions
which can't be answered within its own
terms
within this template itself first of all
how can we explain the variance that we
observe
in the pathways to independence
especially
revolutions on the one hand in their
different forms and different timing
different
varying success on the one hand
and on the other much more staged
managed forms
of decolonization leading to something
more closely
like neocolonial you know forms of
pseudo-independence so for example lee
kuan yew famously derided
malaysia as having one independence
because they were
they were delivered it on a silver
platter by british royalty
you know with a bed of roses rather than
fighting for it
in a kind of heroic fashion sharp
contrast with vietnam
also but then secondly and probably
even more problematically or more
obviously problematic even for
historians rather than
these damn clinical scientists um
[Music]
is this when and where we do see mass
mobilization
uh and revolutionary mass mobilization
how can we explain it when anderson has
told us
that the the broad mass of the
population couldn't possibly be
nationalists
at the time of revolutionary
mobilization
right i mean although anderson's book
tells us that nationalism is interesting
and important
it also tells us that there's a hell of
a lot less nationalism historically
among
far fewer people than we otherwise
previously would have imagined the
people who are nationalists
are going to look like these men they're
going to be male
they're going to be educated and in the
southeast asian context
they are basically the kind of dandies
and flanners
uh who we associate with a certain
social class
because it's only these kinds of mostly
men
who by the turn of the 20th or the the
mid 20th century will be
andersonian in terms of their education
and socialization and immersion
uh in those circuitries of nationalist
socialization and consciousness
that he tells us are so necessary
for people to be nationalists in the
first place so what about the
so-called unwashed masses the broad mass
of the population
that didn't go to school that remained
illiterate unsocialized didn't see the
maps on the school room walls
or circulate through those circuitries
of the colonial state
what about them how did they get
mobilized at all
how is it possible and here it seems to
me that there's a tendency in the
literature
to kind of uh link and kind of
marry the the kind of andersonian
uh elite account uh with uh
a kind of account of of of mass
participation that harks back to the
first distinctive feature
uh of southeast asian studies i
mentioned earlier
namely uh what we see in reyeletta's
book
passion and revolution where he suggests
that there were
distinctively tagalog or filipino
conceptions of kalayaan or freedom
which animated uh you know the
uh the participation in the katipunan in
the in the philippine revolution
or in ben anderson's earlier book java
in the time of revolution
um with its great cover here some of you
might recognize
uh omri widodo um in the photo there
um and and here anderson you know
he he's talking about how a distinctly
javanese conception of power
informed the pamuta the youth uh who
were drawn into
participation and leadership uh in
in sort of spearheading the revolution
or we can take in the case of vietnam
this wonderful quote
from uh uh alexander woodside in his
book community and revolution in modern
vietnam
claiming that no amount of statistics
rhetoric or social science theory
can explain the vietnamese revolution
adequately if its properties of acute
historical consciousness
and cultural pride are insufficiently
considered
so in other words that it was this deep
sense of
shared vietnamese identity and culture
and history and community
that animated mass participation among
ordinary uh vietnamese uh peasants and
participants
in the revolution but it seems to me
that
uh these sorts of accounts
and their linkage to a kind of
andersonian elite
account is inadequate or problematic
in terms of where it leaves us
descriptively and analytically
in descriptive terms it it raises the
question
of what jim scott used to call the
revolution within the revolution how is
it that the commissars
managed to manage the peasants in these
revolutions how is it that
the miscommunications and
misrepresentations in this kind of split
level revolution
in which elites and masses are thinking
in such different terms
was managed clearly very problematic it
also raises questions
in explanatory terms how then could we
explain
the variance that we see in which some
revolutions unfold and others don't and
and some revolutions
uh head in some directions and assume
some forms and other take different ones
and finally i think you know a recent
book by someone who i i saw is in the
audience uh christian lentz
on jian bin fu that the famous you know
battle uh uh that is is kind of a
signifier
for anti-colonial nationalist
independent struggles uh he shows in his
dissertation and then in his his
recently published book
that that in fact the the
thousands of coulee laborers uh
who played such a crucial role in making
the vietnamese
communist party the viet minh's victory
possible
alongside the participation of chinese
military advisors and
military assistants weren't even ethnic
vietnamese or
vietnamese speakers themselves
and they are whom we would describe as
ethnic minorities today instead so in
other words this picture
uh of this template that i've suggested
uh leaves some key questions unanswered
and it's
in in and the the
the kind of go-to uh response
and supplement uh and corrective
uh to this kind of uh
gap in in the template it seems to me is
also inadequate
so against this backdrop the book
republican communism
islam as the title suggests um offers a
different template
not a contradictory template but a
complimentary
template and one that's not by any
stroke
of the of imagination original but it's
rather a composite
sympathis a synthesis of at least
three decades of scholarship by
historians
some of whom are graduates of yale
university um
i i can see there's kevin fogg in the
audience
and his recently published book rian
subianto
whose uh phd and soon to be published
book are
these are these are important works in a
broader trend
in the literature which tells us
something different and if you add them
all up
beginning with perhaps chris gauche's
work
on vietnam mike laffin's work
on indonesia you begin to see
a different kind of picture coming into
view and i'm really just drawing
together these strands
into a composite picture with some
comparative analysis
as well and here the emphasis is not on
the rise of modern states and the
emergence
of nationalism but instead on
long-distance commerce capitalist
development
and cosmopolitan connections and
connectedness
and so we see up into the early modern
era
that rising long-distance trade gives
rise to various forms of cosmopolitanism
there's the so-called sanskrit
cosmopolis that sheldon pollock writes
about
there's the arabic cosmopolis that ronit
richie writes about
there's the so-called cynographic
cosmopolitanism
for vietnam in particular there is
obviously
islamic cosmopolitanism beyond arabic
cosmopolitanism
and there is also catholic
cosmopolitanism
as well through the early modern era
and what i suggest in the book is that
the legacies of these forms of
cosmopolitanism
are in some measure determinant of the
trajectories and outcomes
of the revolutionary mobilizations that
we see in southeast asia centuries later
at the turn of the 20th century in the
philippines and in the mid-20th century
in indonesia and vietnam but really
it's uh the transportation communication
revolutions of the mid late 19th century
and the deepening integration
of southeast asia into the world economy
in the mid-20th century
that overshadows the older cosmopolitan
older cosmopolitanisms and overlays them
with new ones
in concrete institutional forms which
provide
infrastructures for mobilization so it's
during this period that we see the
emergence
of southeast asian cities their linkage
up to market towns
and market and the creation of market
societies
and crucially the tightening integration
of southeast asia into the world economy
doesn't just couple colonies
and metropoles into ever more intimate
intense dyadic embraces but opens the
floodgates
to more diverse influences the
philippine archipelagos
the archipelago the the port cities are
opened
uh and german and british and other
firms come in that dwarf spanish
commerce
in the dutch east indies many of the big
plantations on java and sumatra
are not dutch owned but owned by by
other
european companies and singapore remains
an
important hub for indies trade
up into the late 19th century in if we
take the case
of uh french indochine uh much of
uh the commodities um uh flow
to um especially rice flow to southern
china
and some of the profits flow into
french imperial investments in various
parts of
africa the mercantile classes
that emerge in southeast asia are of
course
in inconsiderable measure of immigrant
stock whether chinese
from fujian and guangdong provinces
indian like the chediars or arab
from the hadramat region of what today
is yemen
so in other words what we see alongside
the kind of andersonian nationalizing or
proto-nationalizing trends
is something very cosmopolitan
in its forms and we can see this in the
distinctively
hybrid and cosmopolitan forms of popular
entertainment
popular opera popular uh
uh you know um uh forms of of
of entertainment that we see in the
cities and towns of southeast asia the
comedy stumble
uh in the indies uh and in the malay
peninsula
which traces its roots back to bombay
kailuang in what's now vietnam which has
diverse
chinese and western influences in terms
of music
and expression or the comedia that we
see
in the philippines after all the uh the
most famous epic poem of the 19th
century
in tagalog literature uh it all
is about a series of events that take
place in albania
of all places so in other words uh what
we see by the turn of the 20th century
in southeast asia
is the emergence of very cosmopolitan
uh sort of cities and towns with
uh cosmopolitan very diverse mercantile
and professional classes
new forms of modern learning knowledge
schooling
and associational activity new forms of
modernity in terms of expression
and association activity forms of modern
consciousness
and so this template suggests this kind
of
teleology instead but leaving open a
realm of indeterminacy
as to when where how or whether at all
it will lead to some form of
revolution-making
and so throughout much of the book what
i try and do
is to hold together an underlying
framework of a kind of
comparative historical sociological
analysis
even while emphasizing the importance of
of major international conjunctures the
spanish-american war
uh the the sino-japanese and uh
russo-japanese wars world war one and of
course world war
ii but the real thrust of the analysis
in the book lies in a more structuralist
kind of comparative historical sociology
with an emphasis on the variance in how
these different southeast asian
societies
played host to different kinds and
different constellations
of cosmopolitan linkages which provided
institutional organizational and
discursive bases for different kinds of
revolutionary mobilization
as signaled in the title republicanism
communism
is long and there are two essential
elements
in the argument along this the lines of
comparative historical sociology
the first is that the early modern era
gave rise to forms of cosmopolitanism
that left legacies
in terms of scholasticism and scholastic
infrastructures that we see
whether catholic or islamic
or cynographic which are important in
their varying tendencies
towards absorption and integration into
existing orders and state structures or
autonomy and independence and evolution
and expansion
outside of the state or evisceration
by modern colonial states and this
matters
in due course and the second thing that
really matters
is what happens in the late 19th and
early 20th century in terms of
class formation in terms of the
emergence of dominant classes
and subaltern classes that vary in
different ways in terms of their
their sort of capacities to serve as
social bases
for different kinds of revolutionary
projects and forms of revolutionary
mobilization
and uh i had initially planned to then
go through
uh this kind of uh account for the
the three revolutions um but i can see
that time is short and that
if i if i proceed along those lines i
will
not leave much time for questions so i
can just give you some choice
quotes here from the concluding chapter
of the book
but give you a flavor of the conclusions
i draw
um this is a kind of a little nugget of
a concluding argument
but if we look at the account of the
philippines uh this is where i come down
in terms of uh emphasizing uh the
importance
of uh an underlying tension and conflict
between an assimilated
chinese mestizo dominant class that
combines
economic social and political power on a
local level
and runs up against increasingly uh
the entrenched powers of the catholic
church in the late 19th century
and has the capacity to articulate and
to lead
um forms of mobilization
in tune with and in sync with
similar kinds of struggles going on in
other parts
of the catholic world in the late 19th
century the so-called cultural wars
culture wars between ultra-montane very
conservative catholicism
and various strands of republicanism and
liberalism
represented by freemasonry most
most particularly and that this is
crucial in terms of
the infrastructure for mobilization and
in terms of
when and where and how and by whom
you know we see this kind of
mobilization
uh it's it's something that um that i
trace
up into the the revolution itself so
that the the figure of
andres bonifacio a key leader uh
in the making of the katipunan the fact
that he
um is uh working for a german company in
manila's chinatown the fact that he had
had worked for
uh had served as an actor in a local
comedia
and the fact that among his books is the
famous book the the wandering jew
which depicts the jesuits as part of
this elaborate
uh conspiracy are all symptomatic
emblematic
of this broader pattern of what made
and also what limited uh the philippine
revolution in terms of the limitations
of its egalitarian promise and its
capacity for
organizational uh uh sort of solidity
in the face of various challenges uh the
katipunan within the katipunan and of
course
the the massive might of the american
military
as they invaded and occupied the
philippines the turn of the 20th century
by contrast if we look at the indonesian
case the emphasis
is on two features of the indonesian
archipelago
that distinguish it from the philippines
and other parts of southeast asia
the first is the the
notable autonomy or independence of
various forms of islamic schooling and
social associational activity which
render it available
for forms of mobilization already in the
early 20th century and during the
revolution
and then on the other hand the
importance and extent of large-scale
plantation
agriculture and railroad
transport and the creation of a
large-scale wage labor-based
industrial proletariat providing the
basis for
left-wing socialist communist
labor organizing and mobilization with
communist
and islamic infrastructures
proving so crucial for mobilization
in the revolucia in the latter half
of the 1940s as shown so brilliantly by
kevin fogg
in his recent book so i i think
you know that without islam and
communism
often derided by official nationalist
accounts as somehow traitors to
the revolution without islam and
communism the revolution would have had
very little oomph to it in terms of the
the energies that it brought
to the revolution uh and yet the failure
of those two
uh kind of cosmopolitan rubrics for
mobilization to combine and fuse
in in a single form uh also limited
their effectiveness
and rendered them vulnerable to
absorption
appropriation and eventual evisceration
by a republican state
after independence and finally in the
vietnamese case
what i suggest is another point of
comparison
um uh if we can get down to it you see
how
how much i hope to go through here
and the crucial thing in the vietnamese
case is twofold
one that the the form of cynographic
cosmopolitanism
that had lasted uh on and off
uh for centuries in vietnamese history
die uh a a death um
just a decade after their disappearance
in neighboring china
uh with the forms of synographic
learning uh and schooling and
socialization
that previously fed into an imperial
state
uh abolished as a new form of
state rule emerges and so the
elimination
of this kind of tradition and this kind
of infrastructure for mobilization for
socialization
communication and mobilization that
lasted into the early 20th century in
vietnam
its elimination meant that that in
vietnam
you didn't have a kind of institutional
counterweight
uh that would that would provide an
alternative basis
uh for uh to communism in the way that
that islamic schools and associations
did uh
in the indies and also crucially
the tight integration of the vietnamese
economy
into uh into the uh into the southern
chinese economy
really rendered uh the uh
local vietnamese and and the insistence
of the
the french colonial regime on
segregating uh
chinese immigrants um really rendered
the local vietnamese business class a
small
marginal uh potential carrier
for uh and social base for a republican
alternative
uh to um to other forms of mobilization
and other kinds of
egalitarian promise and discourse and
revolutionary brotherhood
and this combined with the circumstances
and the geography
of vietnam within indochina within the
french empire and of course his neighbor
of china
really disadvantaged alternatives
and challengers to what became the
monolithic
monopoly of the viet minh and the
communist party
over the revolutionary struggle uh and
and so it's it's this kind of
comparative analysis
combined with uh an attention to
um international conjunctures uh
and various forms of sympathy support
and solidarity
in different parts of the world that
provides the canvas
uh for uh the the accounts i give of
these revolutions
and the way in which i roll out this
initial template
into an account of the trajectories and
outcomes of these revolutions providing
a kind of denationalized
internationalized and transnationalized
account
of revolutions in southeast asia sorry
for going on for so long
um but uh there may be many questions
uh about the the book and um the good
news is
uh you can read the book uh and you can
also
purchase the book at a serious discount
um
and and get all the answers there so
thank you and sorry for going over
thank you john no need to apologize at
all it's a fascinating talk
um i'm sure we're gonna have a lot of
questions i'm going to stop sharing the
screen just so that we can all see each
other's faces and create a little bit of
community here
during the q a so everyone
please raise your hand use the hand
function and if you can't figure out how
to do that send me a text through the
chat function
or wave your hand wildly and eventually
i'll see you
um but let's start um with whoever has
the first question
i'd also like kevin's about to has a
question i
was about to mention kevin's name i
wanted to
invite both kevin and christian lentz um
to share their book uh book links out of
modesty they probably won't want to do
that but they were both called
out in the lecture so i give them
permission to share their
links to their books to the rest of us
because i'm sure i can pull copies off
my shelves
yeah so we'll start with kevin and then
a question from christian right after
that and then
we'll think that's that's very kind of
you eric and thank you john so much for
a really interesting engagement the
question that i wondered and i'm not
sure the book goes this far
is about some of the near misses in
southeast asia
um you i don't want to say derided but
you quoted lee kuan yew to deride the
malaysian cases getting handed
independence on a silver platter
but they did have um a quote-unquote
emergency for 10 years they did have
folks who wanted a revolutionary
direction
you know there are other countries in
southeast asia where this could have
happened
and there are also ways in which the the
countries that we wound up with i mean
indonesia might not have wound up as
indonesia it could have wound up as two
things or as five things
um i as a historian there's some worry
when we look at this big structural
thing that you've accepted the
structures that came after and then gone
back to explain
them instead of wondering what could
have happened otherwise do you talk at
all about the near misses or the
contingencies in this
and where that might have gone for
others should i go ahead and answer
individual questions eric yeah please do
okay
that's a great question i mean not
they're in a way two elements of an
answer
uh one is that i do extend very briefly
in the
conclusion the analysis to cover other
countries in southeast asia
so i take indonesia and then look at
malaysia and say well
yes on the one hand we see you know a
very impressive form
of malayan communist party mobilization
and insurrectionary activity that lasts
up into the you know from the late 40s
into the 1950s
but it's limited uh in considerable
measure
revisionist historians question this but
in large measure to the
the chinese uh population and and to
certain segments of the population in
terms of social class
and i think the a contrast with in terms
of islam is also very strong
that you can see that in contrast with
indonesia where you have
uh you know basically islam is left
outside
uh the control of the colonial state
it's not controlled by the the local
aristocracy
that's very different under british
colonial rule and you have nothing like
the kind of infrastructure of autonomous
independent
um you know mobilizational capacity and
you have it also a very different
um form of class formation the javanese
peasantry compared to the malay
peasantry uh
very different so there is there is that
i do play out that structuralist
analysis in terms of the comparison now
to get to your
um uh you're not a proper historian
you're just one of these damn political
scientists who are who are
retrospectively
cherry-picking the history and avoiding
the um
the the kind of uh alternative you know
moments and conjunctures so i i do talk
about the sadhaka islam
and there is new scholarship coming out
about that and
about that period and you yourself are
working on these possibilities
for uh sort of combining islam and
communism and and i do dwell
quite a bit on that and how
and how if not fully why it doesn't
happen
like the nature and extent to which it
it begins to
come together and then it unravels and
it happens
you know across the 20th century in many
different contexts
and you know if ali shariati had not
died just before the iranian revolution
would
with things have gone differently we
don't have
you know it it seems to be a broader
pattern so i'm
i i kind of end up um
at least giving some time and space to
the woulda coulda shoulda's
um uh if if not you know
at least dwell on them
thank you
[Music]
eric should i go ahead yeah thanks john
i was just going to ask christian to ask
his question
please do well first let me just say i
think as i just said to eric in a chat
i'm still blushing um
john for your nice call out of my book
and it's very kind of you too
i'm also quite honored to be mentioned
in the same breath as
kevin filed my colleague here
um available monograph about the sort of
anarchism and its role
in southeast asian history and so it
seems to me what you're doing then is
you're sort of bringing
this sort of late anderson into dialogue
with early anderson and his work in
imagined communities to try and
it was a work of synthesis then rather
than a rejection of that earlier
um sort of as you call a template for
national consciousness
plus i guess my comment and then my
question is um
all of us who have gone to yale and
cornell um again i'm just
referring to the shout out from eric
before are well aware that our
um field of southeast asian studies came
of age in the united states during the
cold war
and so i think there is as you suggest
an argument for the kind of national
list nationalist reading of southeast
asian history as a way to counter
the american imperial project to put it
quickly so
given that we are now in this different
moment right what do you think are the
essential ingredients for this
revisiting
of southeast asian studies um are we all
now
under the sort of um the
the lure if you will of globalization to
try and think about southeast asia in a
more decentered way
what do you think are the sort of
fundaments if you will of the
intellectual situation that are
contributing to this revision
thank you great great questions
um in terms of ben anderson's under
three flags
um i mean he uh i
i've been working on this project since
uh
embarrassingly since 2003 um
and so and he was aware of what i was
doing and
and i think you know and he was
supportive of it so it's not written
the book is dedicated to him um and is
not written
against him and i i actually there's a
great quote from under three flags
that i included in the book because the
uh the readers the reviewers of the
manuscript said you know there's
we're not completely one of them at
least said i'm not fully comfortable
with the way in which you're engaging
you know and within framing this book
and there's a bit of concern about that
so i i think i make clear that that
i'm you know that it's the template
rather than the book and that that
to go back to kevin's question of well
could indonesia have looked different
you know those sorts of issues i i
think that there's a kind of impressive
longevity
to imagine communities in terms of
almost an implicit or explicit
uh prediction that these nations will
stay as such
um in terms of their boundaries and and
so i think you know
if you're interested in those sorts of
questions um with the interesting
rickles which
chris goshen offers in the case of
indochina you know
i i would say you know i i fully um
endorse that it is the template
and so to to get to your final question
i think um
i think if we are going to you know
not be so concerned uh with saying oh
southeast asians are ineffably southeast
asian in some way
or southeast asians are are really
deeply nationalists
in some way but instead we're gonna
we're gonna
do kind of global history or world
history then it's important to make sure
that southeast asians are seen as actors
in this and there's a wonderful uh phd
thesis from the university of hawaii
which shows how it's not only as as
scholars tell us that the first
globalization
began in manila with the connection of
asian american and european trade made
possible through the galleon
but it's that filipino shipbuilders
filipino loggers filipino workers who
repaired and built ships and then
filipino sailors who
navigated these ships back across the
pacific they played a crucial role
and so it's not just that manila was
like a kind of
you know a site for this but that
filipinos were active
crucial participants it didn't just
happen in southeast asia
and so you know it i i i think it's
crucial for the accounts to be
you know to show the active uh creative
roles of southeast asians making the
most if not always the best of
of globalizations and and i guess in
political terms
for me maybe something that somehow
still stays with me is
in i don't know is it 2010 the election
here in the uk
all three very conventional and
conservative
politicians when asked who are running
for prime minister
when asked who they admired most in the
world they all said oh nelson mandela
nelson mandela nelson mandela
and and so you know nelson mandela is
cute and cuddly
as a kind of you know hero struggling
for
uh south african nationalism as it were
but the fact that he was
you know uh supported by if not
a member of the south african communist
party
you know that that rendered him
untouchable and like no one would shake
his hand or
or asked for him to get out of jail all
those long years in the 20th century
so it's quite hypocritical and um
a convenient forgetfulness for us to
forget
the role of the communists and the the
islamists or the role of communism and
islam
in the making of the indonesian
revolution of all sorts of inconvenient
people in the making of the vietnamese
revolution
as you show us and and and and then you
know so i think
to denationalize can be helpful because
i think we've seen a great deal of
renationalization
and recentralization of power in
different parts of the world
in the past 10 20 years
in russia and china in turkey and india
in the united states like
why not continue to to work to
denationalize
yeah john i'm gonna
jump in with a question i see that
kelvin has a question but i
i didn't see the hand until right now
and i've already started asking my
question technically so
i'll forge ahead um and then kelvin will
be right after um
i wanted to ask you a little bit about
this term that you used scholasticism
exactly what you mean by that and it may
be a term of art that i just i'm not
up on the language um and how you call
that a certain
a certain kind of cosmopolitan
connection
um and how you might differentiate that
from you know ben anderson's famous
points about print capitalism
because it seems that's also a kind of
cosmopolitan
connection and i'm wondering are you
are you arguing against the formative
role of print capitalism or are you
trying to say that there
are more there are other forms of
cosmopolitan
connections that are sort of
we we ignore them when we pay too much
attention to a certain kind of
cosmopolitanism
and i also wanted to use this as an
opportunity to
make a mention of next week's brown bag
because kathleen gutierrez's work
on botany is actually sounds to me like
it's actually
unexpectedly doing the same kind of
thing that you're talking about
because she talks about how through the
rise of botany
in the philippines there's a kind of
botanical cosmopolitanism that emerges
and there was a concept of southeast
asia that she describes
called melisia which was a floristic
zone
like a floristic region among the
scientific community
and so i think there's a kind of
unexpected convergence there
and also some other the scholarship that
i you know recently been out claire
eddington's work on colonial psychiatry
talks a lot about how
the psychiatrists in colonial and sheen
were looking to the dutch psychiatrists
um to get ideas about how to create
new uh you know asylums and those kinds
of things so there's
an interesting emergence of the
scholarship
that seems to be doing what you're doing
but without the kind of
nice framework that you're giving it to
and so i wanted to signal that
remind everyone to come to next week's
brown bag and also
just ask you to clarify the difference
between the scholasticism
and your form of cosmopolitan connection
and that famous idea of print capitalism
okay great question um
so if you look at imagine communities
you'll see that
ben anderson talks about kind of
pre-national forms of cosmopolitan
consciousness that he associates with uh
sacred languages that one might link to
you know very broad transoceanic trans
continental kind of religious
communities
whether it's latin or pali
or arabic classical arabic or classical
chinese
and i guess what i see as significant
is much more specific namely the the
institutions
of of scholarly or scholastic activity
that we see
in terms of seminaries in terms of what
turn into the madrasas or the passontren
[Music]
you know over over centuries
and their counterparts in vietnam that
are are
analogous and interrelated to their to
what's happening in china in terms of
you know every year and these patterns
of circulation and connectedness
that are sociologically quite
interesting and important
because you know if in village schools
there are people studying
you know the four books and the five
classics
uh and then they they go to the town and
then they go to the bigger market town
and then they go to the provincial
capital and eventually they go to hue
you know for um you know for the exams
um that that is a a form of
connectedness
over decades and centuries that you
you then would see in with islamic
counterparts or in terms of
uh catholic schools and seminaries
and and that's very important i think it
is
it is notably uh almost all male
um so it's similar to anderson's
emphasis on kind of schoolboy
nationalism in a way um but i think that
these these kinds of
connectedness they regardless of the
content
they have different forms and they have
different histories in terms of what
happens to them
they evolve and and attach themselves
into
states and then they die if the state
dispenses with them as
we see in vietnam in the case of islam
they
evolve and evolve and survive outside of
the states
and we see in the case of catholicism
they evolve in diverse
and conflicted directions so i think
that
it's important to trace those histories
because i think that they are
they vary in ways that are important um
in for these revolutions and for these
societies
so that's what i mean by these sorts of
so they're pre-modern
forms of cosmopolitanism um and
scholasticism
that then you know evolve with modernity
and with their new experiments with um
you know islamic modernism islamic
reformism
you know even the dominicans decide they
have to teach
medicine and science in the late 19th
century
uh which the jesuits are doing you know
decades early
so i think that's that's what i mean and
that's what i emphasize in the book
um so it's a bit of that kind of
it's a bit like the southeast asian
studies
that's great i actually think um that if
you looked more into vietnamese
catholicism too although the numbers are
not the same
for the philippines so they don't create
the possibility of total
revolutionary uh transformation but
some of the same dynamics you're
describing also take place in vietnamese
catholicism
and the kind of you know circulation of
a cosmopolitan network
there's actually even a secondary layer
of
almost an alternative state system with
different counties yeah
like like these parish style counties
um that are totally give you a different
geography
of what is known as the nation of
vietnam yeah
but i'll let kevin ask his question
after kevin we have a question from
jennifer gaynor
and then after jennifer will turn to
rhian soup giant
hi professor seidel thank you so much
for your presentation as well as for
your book
uh i i thought it's really interesting
and there's someone working broadly on
this
interval moment of various international
projects i
i i found just the ambition of your book
to be incredibly sort of
admirable um i have a question which is
which really builds on professor harm's
question
on uh scholasticism and cosmopolitanism
and i guess i'm really curious about
your use of the term cosmopolitanism
in relation to other terms that may be
in circulation during this period
um so if you look at the common tune and
if you look at the baku conference
i believe that a term that most of this
cohort of marxist was using was
internationalism
and if you look at different the
different projects of islam is modernism
and of pan-islamism on the subcontinent
and in southeast asia
the vision of universalism that they
posited was one of
the ummah as they took the omaha it's so
a spatial scale of reference
um and i guess um the term
cosmopolitanism as you as you mentioned
um in a different sort of
conceptualization
seems to be very linguistic
linguistically bound so you have the
sanskrit cosmopolis you have the arabic
cosmopolis you have the
persian cosmopolis um and i was
wondering if you could elaborate a bit
more about the perhaps the differences
and similarities where they converge and
where they diverge there's different
scales of thinking theorizing
universalism
how is internationalism perhaps a
different or similar project compared to
cosmopolitanism what uh analytically
what do they open up in terms of how we
think about
these projects um and
and how might we think about the role of
language
and perhaps forging these new links in
in this late 19th early 20th century
moment keeping in mind
for instance what uh ben anderson and uh
under three flags would describe as the
the true internationalism of the
polyglot right
um and i guess like a related question
to that centers around this really
fascinating figure
in your first chapter of uh musai sultan
galiyev and
um him being you know the so-called
architect of
uh muslim quote unquote national
communism in in the soviet union
um in his sort of resolution of the
tatar uh kyrgyzia
um central asian question i was
wondering to what extent was
was uh was that quite uh if sultan galea
himself attempted to
um think about the minoritized status of
muslims in the soviet union through the
frame of national communism
he's implicitly positing a sort of
congruence between the project of
internationalist communism with one of
nationalism on the other
and so i i guess to what extent would
that apply to
southeast asia where nationalism and
internationalism rather than being
opposed to one another
might actually be consonant or congruent
with
with each other in in in the sort of in
sultan galeaf sense
um but thank you so much again for your
presentation
that's the most that's like the toughest
question
anyone could could ever ask
it's a really great question and i think
my
knowledge and skills and theoretical
sophistication
you know would would you know really
constrain me to
to really undertake a kind of ambitious
project to kind of compare
cosmopolitanisms so-called but i think
you're
you're absolutely right um in your
suggestion that
they must vary considerably in terms of
what they really consist of and comprise
um
and and i think you know most
most clearly in like in in your your
comment about
sultan galiyev and of communist
internationalism
or muslim you know national communism
that the nation state is part of it
you know in sheldon pollock's or other
versions of the sanskrit cosmopolis
that there's a great deal of attention
to court culture
and court literature and so forth but
there isn't a conception of a
anything resembling a like a broader
community
um and and that might also be true in in
forms of
cynographic so-called cosmopolitanism
where there's a conception of
uh civilized rather than barbarian
behavior and of
you know a forms of propriety and
refinement and
and knowledge that that don't embrace a
broader community in the way that an uma
um uh might do so i i think
there is huge variance and uh in in how
these
these so-called cosmopolitanisms operate
and i'm painfully aware that
among political theorists and and uh
scholars of international relations and
and and other disciplines that the term
cosmopolitanism
is used in many different ways and for
me it's
it's kind of futile that i'm using it um
given the alternatives to to use the
term transnationalism
clearly doesn't suffice and i think it's
worth you know nodding back in the
direction of imagined communities
um where where anderson himself uses the
term
uh and to begin with with some you know
attention to that
that kind of the legacies of those
pre-national forums of connectedness
so you know the book is um
will be disappointing to readers uh with
great theoretical
sophistication um i i think
um far from it it's not disappointing at
all
i greatly really enjoyed it okay well
many thanks
and and thanks for the great question
and you know i'm glad that there are
other people interested in sultan
galiyev
because you know to go back to um uh
kevin fogg's question i think he's he's
one of these interesting
kind of also rands of history you know
sort of like tom malacca
you know in terms of what what he
represented in terms of possibilities
even working under stalin
[Music]
thank you um jennifer gainer you had a
question and then after jennifer
we will have rihanna soup giant
first i just want to say thank you john
for a wonderful talk and i can't wait to
read the book so
take anything i have to say with a grain
of salt because i haven't read the book
yet
but i'm really looking forward to it um
and i'm sort of surprised that you
haven't mentioned
takashi shiraishi and all this sort of
influences on you because his age
emotion
feels like it's been a big influence in
the conceptualization of the project
is that i don't know if that's true but
um
i mean who else could have brought in
not just women trip but you know taking
us over to zenovia
and then gardetsky not just guangzhou i
mean i love the way
i can't wait to read that kind of
writing it sounds like it's really fun
um but i want to um pick up on something
you just said
and follow up on kelvin kelvin's comment
um you mentioned the legacies of pre-nat
pre-national forms of connectedness
and i'm just wondering you know in using
uh maybe we do need to theorize
cosmopolitanism
more explicitly and better because it's
a wonderful
notion but i wonder to what degree it
does kind of
reinscribe the idea of a dichotomy
between
the internal autonomous authentic
southeast asia thing
versus this externally generated
cosmopolitanism idea or whatever it is
you know
mercantile expanse expansion or
um you know various forms of uh
of connectedness that have come outside
in that this is a false dichotomy in
in my eyes so i'm just wondering if
there's room in thinking
about the precursors to these
cosmopolitan linkages
for forms that maybe could have started
in southeast asia
and simultaneously linked up to these
cosmopolitanisms so that's
that's one thing i wanted to mention and
then the other thing since
since i'm here um it's just where were
the women in these revolutions
or was the role of women just
sociologically incidental
great questions i i i i can see three
core questions there the second i'm not
fully sure i i fully get but let let me
try
at least two of them and then get on to
the the middle one
so in in terms of takashi shiraishi he
definitely
is acknowledged in the acknowledgments
as an important influence
given the course i took with him as a
graduate student and the kind of
panoramic
comparative historical sociologically
informed account he gave
of a modern southeast asian history but
also
you know as you mentioned an age in
motion and that interest in [ __ ]
misbach
and in the sarakat islam and so forth
which
as uh you know we'll see also um
you know in in is being revisited by
other scholars
um these days as well
so i think um that interest in what did
and didn't happen
between islam and communism is there and
in the book there's
i spent a lot of time on the sarakat
islam and there's a lot of
of of takashi there so so that's there
in terms of the the question of gender
and of women in particular
i think i belatedly realized um
towards the end of the book that there's
an argument that i would like to
bring out perhaps in an article um
that kind of teases it out more
explicitly
and that links back to this the this
notion of
scholastic cosmopolitanism
um and so in so far as these forms of
pre-modern and early modern uh
scholasticism are overwhelmingly male
their survival um or their
uh demise has implications
not only in terms of politics but also
in terms of gender
and what i see is distinctive in the
vietnamese revolution
is that the demise
of this kind of
you know uh infrastructure
uh by the 19 teens
in vietnam opens up
a field of educational
experience and socialization um
that you know doesn't have the kind of
male
only uh qualities and restrictions
on it that we see in the islamic schools
and in the um you know that we see in
the in the late 19th century philippines
uh heavily as well and i think that
if you look at the vietnamese revolution
the role of women is really striking
i mean we have so many different
accounts of the role of women and it's
you know women hold up half the sky um
the the vietnamese revolution you know
compared to what people have been able
to show about
uh 20th century uh indonesian
revolutionary or filipino
left-wing politics i think there's a
much more impressive
uh history that shows that there's
there are implications here in terms of
uh
women's participation so i think that's
that's the story and if people have said
well you know
that the book suggests but it doesn't it
doesn't draw it out with
the kind of evidence that i think i
could could glum together it for an
article
to make that kind of comparative case
more explicitly
and extensively but i think it's i think
there's something like that
that is important um in terms of the
the the different implications of these
different histories for
you know these institutions of
reproducing patriarchy
and and uh male forms of male
male monopoly on certain forms of
knowledge religious knowledge and so
forth
um in terms of the the dangers of a kind
of
cosmopolitanism at the expense of like
that oh
all southeast asians are cosmopolitans
or that
like a kind of unidirectional account i
mean
i guess in the book what i i'm trying to
do is to suggest that
the ways in which these societies were
constituted
and evolved you know
had a lot to do with various different
external elements and what became
vietnamese what became
filipino it became indonesian you know
had it
had outside and inside intertwined
um so i think that that's what i'm
trying to suggest and maybe didn't
articulate it well
but i can see that i'm privileging you
know the coasts
over the interiors you know i i am
the they're it's uh
[Music]
there there's you know there's a lot
that's maybe
getting missed there right um
and and so it could be the you know the
pendulum is swinging too far
back um you know in in my account
um and and the proof has to be in the
southeast asian pudding
you know in terms of do you know i guess
my interest is less
in and my my confidence is less in
an understanding in consciousness
but rather in some kind of sociology
and so if we ask ourselves how the
people we read about
in mary steedly's account of the
indonesian revolution
or in accounts of these little towns in
in tonkin
in you know 1945 when they hear about
you know independence being declared in
hanoi
um you know how did these people
what possibilities were there for
organizing and mobilizing and what
possibilities were foreclosed
sociologically institutionally that's
what i feel more
confident is knowable at least for me
yeah okay thank you thanks for this
stimulating
discussion um our last question will be
from
riyon subignto and i want to apologize i
think i
have misspelled rhiaon's name twice in
my chat
um my eyes can't read my tiny screen
very well so
uh apologies to you rihanna but you can
have the last question
no problem thank you so much um
hi john it's very nice to meet you
finally
my question is uh it's thank you for so
much for the book obviously it's uh
it's brilliant and it's uh it gives a
fresh new
um pathways for research in southeast
asia
and my question is on cosmo on the idea
of cosmopolitanism and i was thinking
here what makes it uh cosmopolitanism
um and what you've mentioned is
cosmopolitanism is forms
of connectedness and infrastructure so
is it ideology
because when we think about ideology
which is what you talk about also
right of course you talk about the
infrastructure there are traces of
nationalism
or what i like to say parochialism
instead of nationalism in islam and
communism
right um and also nationalism is very
much cosmopolitan
in a sense that it is a template that's
become copied
elsewhere so um so i was thinking that
maybe instead of thinking of
cosmopolitanism versus nationalism we're
thinking about cosmopolitanism versus
parochialism
and then what makes it cosmopolitan is
maybe is it also material because then
if we think of it as material in terms
of shipping lines
conte you know infrastructure of context
media and language then we can trace
those um and in terms of the nature of
those contexts because
in the history of indonesian communism
in the in the early 1920s
uh duri for example during the
underground time after
um the revolt in 1927-26 right
yamaluddin tamim and all of the other
fellow
uh communist exiles they went to
singapore and malaysia but their network
is very much
among the muslim you know malay people
it's not really
with the for example the communist
chinese
in malaysia so so tracing that
very um specific specificity of the of
cosmopalatinism is very important and
then also
and then this is my second question what
is the characteristics or maybe origin
which i don't really like the word but
characters of cosmopolitan
cosmopolitanism that is specifically
southeast asia
in other words what is south asian
southeast asian contribution to the
history of cosmopolitanism
more tough questions about
cosmopolitanism
[Music]
um i i guess for me you know as
you know if you look at the root of the
term you know
cosmos and cosmopolitanism
there there seems to be a claim and an
aspiration
um to something that transcends the
specific to some kind of
you know world global universality
that one can identify in in these
different
cases that you know with it is of course
a form of denial erasure
suppression disavowal
of specificity of self-interest
of parochialisms um you know
there is no view from nowhere right um
and and so i think in that sense what
what i
i find noteworthy and and perhaps
uh appealing in these different
cosmopolitanisms
in different ways and to different
extents is
the the seeds at least the ones that i s
that are i focus on in the book and in
the revolutionary context is they each
have
um some degree of emancipatory
and uh egalitarian promise
but they they also have within them
something else they also have within
them you know
forms of domination forms of patriarchy
forms of inequality forms of
exploitation
forms of they have other things there
too and and they have the
the seeds of of state making um
as well but i think
historically the if if you take the
template the template
is the emergence of these sorts of
energies
and forms of mobilization that
contribute to a revolution
and then after a revolution and we can
see this
after the russian revolution you can see
this in art and literature
uh and architecture as much as you can
see it in political terms
then there's the you know italization
the the appropriation by the state
by the nation-state in the 20th century
uh
and and the kind of evisceration of
those more
ambiguous emancipatory energies
um that are then appropriated or
suppressed
um and so maybe part of the project to
go back to some of the earlier questions
also
is to tis is to kind of as with your
work
to kind of remind people of of other
times and other places
when these kinds of hopes and dreams
inspired action
that then was appropriated by others
um and and and that some of those
emancipatory energies many of those
emancipatory energies were then
uh you know absorbed and uh
and killed off and the the origins and
energies were then disavowed
um and and i don't know if that fully
answers your question in terms of
southeast asian contributions
to cosmopolitanism i think
you know i think it's it's clear that
southeast asia has come
has really contributed a great deal to
globalization
um to communist internationalism to
different forms of revolutionary
internationalism
and even in the more conventional
international the kind of bandung
forms of solidarity so i think you know
i begin the book
by saying you know you know when che
guevara said
you know in in havana in 1966
we'll bring you one two three more
vietnam's
everyone knew what he was talking about
he just had to say the word vietnam
and and and people knew what he meant um
you know so i think that there's
southeast asia has been
you know is an incredibly just as
it contributed in many ways to the study
of nationalism and to nationalist
struggles
it also has contributed to these sorts
of forms of internationalism
and cosmopolitanism as well
thank you thank you so much john
we're now at the end of our time i'm
going to stop the record
uh right now and we can those who wish
to linger for informal chat can do so
so i'll click the button here